what's happening now is the software
starting to take on its own life and
building completely new kinds of
processes that never existed in paper
before and those are what's really
differentiating businesses and so the
lifecycle of those and the change rate
of those changes as fast as people can
consume them and this is a big change
from a once-a-year deployment so we have
enterprises doing 20 deployments a week
and and so that clock speed change and
that style of process change that's
happening is really remarkable so this
is where you hear this word digital
transformation which I don't open with
but that's really what all of these
changes lead up to that changes I think
at the heart of sort of the pivotal and
Google partnership which is we're really
bringing the ability to go compete with
software and be great at software and do
it in a scalable data integrated way to
all these large enterprises we used to
have scarce giant resources like
mainframes and the few heroes who could
use them but now of that abundance of
computation it's basically free now from
1992 to 2012 the cost of computation
dropped by a factor of three thousand
seven hundred the cost of storage
dropped by a factor of eighteen thousand
nine hundred so you think about the
absolute all-out abundance of
computational infrastructure well then
you've got a new scarcity the scarcity
is actually the developers not the
infrastructure so what they want what
they want to deploy the things they can
imagine actually have a much bigger
impact on your business
done the cost of the infrastructure we
focused on developer productivity from
another point of view which is how can
you build billion user experiences that
can rapidly iterate based on what users
want and not also burden those
developers with understanding scale and
reliability so we've taken our internal
competencies which we call technical
infrastructure it's the opposite of my
team get it it's ti about 11,000
engineers who do nothing but support the
other 40,000 engineers who support Gmail
search ads right we have seven different
businesses that have over a billion
users each so that partnership is
actually how Google runs it's all about
developer productivity for our
developers the partnership with pivotal
is about bringing the best of what we
know about
that infrastructure is to the best of
what pivotal knows which is what are the
runtime platforms in the tooling like
spring that developers really love
because it just gets out of their way
and they get things done if your
software practice is not incredibly
agile your business process is stuck in
concrete and you won't evolve it's very
satisfying to sit here a year later and
say kubernetes and Cloud Foundry are
coming together very pragmatically in
some obvious ways but also some
surprising and very beautiful ways the
de-risking of open-source helps you
reduce the migration cost rate you can
bet on kubernetes you can bet on Cloud
Foundry and know that there are vibrant
multi vendor communities everybody's
worried about making the wrong choice
and so how are they D risking their
decisions so that they can make a
decision now and everybody's worried
about developer productivity we've got a
shared infrastructure the shared
management layer and Bosh we've got a
shared service broker so you can get to
all the same services like data services
or analytic services machine wedding
services whatever you want wherever you
are so just make it work so that joint
engineering customer obsession and this
focus on eliminating this risk of this
or that by making an and there's a
really big deal and if you watch where
the puck is going there's a lot more
coming the truth is values only found in
the market by customer interaction what
you start with is always wrong and then
you have to incremental II get it less
wrong so it's all about cycle time and
velocity I can iterate my product based
on customer feedback in one week and
somebody else takes a month then I can
get 52 cycles in a year and they only
get 12 my soft will be so much smarter
because it's compounding interest so
that's what I mean when I say you have
to bet on velocity so when you look at
the pivotal Sprint's when you look at
the two-week release cycles that you get
in Cloud Foundry when you look at the
nine ten thousand times that we release
offer per day in Google like we're
companies who have been practicing
velocity for a long time I authentically
believe we've gotten a great opportunity
and there's no two better companies to
go and do this for the world than
pivotal and